jol herzlich willkommen zu diesem blog
und wir werden später noch einen see
gehen zusammen mit lehrern und einem
anderen kumpel von mir und noch immer
kommt wird von mir und da ein paar
fragen beantworten jetzt gerade arbeite
ich an den video welches am samstag dann
hoffentlich angekommen ist und zwar war
das dieses video mit den figuren in
katjas dicke lippe werde auf geld hat
dann arbeitet ist der macht gerade alle
drei systeme mit den lamas philips mit
seinen shows schon fertig ich nicht ich
muss nämlich noch sagen die machen
nebenbei die videos für heute stehen
aber gott sei dank schon was natürlich
nicht für das kind heute abend fehlen
darf sind fragen die leute ich stellte
mir noch gerne mal fragen zum thema
reisen und freizeit ich freue mich und
aids zu machen und überlegt euch gerne
was tiefsten das war so den fragen sind
gestellt über den film sorry übrigens
folgt mir gerne mal auf instagram jetzt
gerade in zukunft kommen wieder aktiv
bilder von mir lieber nicht war nämlich
gestern beim fotoshooting auch beim
philipp könnte gerne vorbeischauen
nämlich richtig coole bilder richtig
gute bilder macht derweil macht sich da
wirklich richtig coole bilder und dann
würde ich sagen sehen wir uns wieder
wenn wir beim supermarkt sind die beiden
sind schon hier der lehr und ist
allerdings noch nicht hier wie war das
leben wollte unbedingt früher los von
der perfekt auf jeden fall kaufen wir
uns jetzt noch ein paar dinge an die wir
dann elektrischen abonnieren können und
dann geht's ab zum see auch wenn das
wetter jetzt nicht unbedingt dazu
einlädt hoffentlich letztlich regnen
wobei es wird regnen der wetterbericht
haben wir folgendes es fällt schnee bis
in die niederungen wirklich besteht
klartext ganz geil aber wir werden
trotzdem werden egal was das wetter will
und jetzt geht es auf zum einen kann
[Musik]
so wir sind jetzt im nirgendwo in einem
riesen rom meer gekippt alter kann man
wieder raus hier komme ich nicht mehr
weiß leon
ich habe ja sollen wieder zunehmen weil
ich komme zu dir wir hier immer hier
hänge fest keiner party urlaub kommt
jungs habt doch nicht so schlimm kann es
dabei jetzt ernsthaft wollen
aber wir wollen wir hier auch wählen
wenn ihr über gebüsch ist ja so schön
ist es lohnt sich auf jeden fall ein
bisschen
man sollte aber schön ist es schon
also ich will jetzt hoch gehen dann
wieder zum auto und dann essen holen
dann gehen wir darüber
ja und wir gehen jetzt eine ahnung sagte
lass uns aufteilen
das ist die beste idee jetzt geht's so
hoch dass denn wie soll das denn was im
meer gekommen
das ist der angenehmste badesee
überhaupt leute sind überall diese
geisteskranken also ich habe jetzt hier
am boden und auch liegen ihr die ganzen
toren rum
wenn wir jetzt das essen wollen lässt
sich schon mal die erste frage vor und
zwar die annika frage was machst du denn
so wie wir gerade mal nicht da ist und
schon fertig mit dem schneiden von
videomaterial willst dann mach ich denke
wie diese hier und zwar einfach mich
inzwischen frittieren er auf jeden fall
mache ich dann meistens eigentlich meine
eigenen videos aber ich habe ja
eigentlich von selig schon relativ viel
zu tun das ist jetzt nicht so dass oft
vorkommt dass ich irgendwie noch so
wahnsinnig viel freizeit auf die eigene
videos aber für die letzten tage habe
ich für dieses fordert video was am
samstag hoffentlich anderen gekommen
sind ganz viel gemacht wir nehmen das
hier schon am freitag auf und der block
wieder aber erst am mittwoch kommt haben
wir grillen bei euch wer bist du echt im
wasser als ob er da drüben wasser ist
zivilisation und er sitzt jetzt schon
darauf die um einen ich würde einfach
angeschlossen
wieso weiß leon ich weiß es nicht
also so is s t shirt das also was ist
denn mit diesem t-shirt los und was ist
denn mit nicht liebe dich so erhalten
platz gefunden wo wir grillen und baden
dürfen jetzt können wir endlich diesen
film machen und was leckeres essen so
die location jetzt auch schon perfekt
leute ja nicht irgendwer fragt hast du
einen traum reiseziel oder hast du die
möglichkeit schon gehabt ich mal sagen
schweden und norwegen ist aber alle
fälle ganz unten war eigentlich nie so
aber jetzt habe ich schon richtig druck
drauf so dass heißt raum reiseziel so
dieses klischee so neuseeland momentan
habe ich am allermeisten bock auf rock
auf unseren weg gemeinsam rufen fragt
wie viele kilometer ist angereist das
meiste was ich glaube
weil es ganz viel das sind auf jeden
fall das was hier steht
ok hockey man warum hat sie kann ihn
haben sich aussprechen lesen block ii
you fragt was für andere kannst du auch
deine reise mit also auf meine
bisherigen reisen zum beispiel und
namibia und auch griechenland und
spanien und frankreich habe ich die
panasonic a4 mitgenommen was eine sehr
tolle kameras aber ich habe ja
mittlerweile diese kamerabasierten auf
jeden fall habe ich jetzt die
sony-server 3 und er weiß nicht aus
das kann man diese auf jeden fall echt
voll gut die gute lotti blumenland fragt
wenn du hast guckst du dir er so das
land oder die menschen und wie sie leben
an
er guckt sich mehr so den kamera
bildschirm haben gar nicht erst mal die
frage an sebastian wenn du reist guckst
du dir er so das land oder die menschen
an und wie sie leben er das land weil
das ding ist wenn man irgendwo im
ausland ist gerade in asien oder so wenn
wir auch im menschen immer schon so
komisch angeguckt leon kennt das ihr
auge komisch auch in europa wenn du
heißt guckst du dir er so das land auf
hörder die menschen an und wie sie leben
das land ja also ich bisher auch aber
ich habe auch eigentlich schon lust
drauf so immens so jetzt natürlich die
frage der first die striche und das aus
first schon da war ja ja ja ich weiß
nicht genau wie er hat gefragt stell dir
vor man stelle vor man würde statt zwölf
jahren schule zwölf jahren die welt
geraten glaubt man wäre besser ausleben
wie bei pokémon größer general trust ii
an den förster oder macht magath alle
weitermachen luisa und sogar die augen
offen über die ja genau denn luiz auf
jeden fall schlagbar sein instagram aus
der macht nämlich auch über alle inseln
bilder im gegensatz zu lehrern bericht
würde zwölf jahre auf reisen geht in dem
alter wenn man tun wenn man verhungert
so direkt abgesprochen verhungert also
ich könnte mir vorstellen dass man
angenommen würde vielleicht nur neun
jahren sind es also acht jahre zur
schule gehen und danach gleich zu vier
jahre weltreise nach nachdem man aber
schon passiert was im kopf hat dann
könnte es sein aber je nachdem was man
machen will
wenn man jetzt irgendwie einen physik
doktor machen will oder wenn man jetzt
generell arzt werden will dann wäre es
vielleicht sinnvoll ein bisschen länger
noch zu in der schule zu bleiben aber so
allgemein für ein erfülltes leben wenn
man irgendwie anders als ein brötchen
kommt jetzt zum beispiel mit videos oder
ja aber nicht die sportler oder was ich
oder musiker natürlich ghriskey ist aber
wenn man das schaffen würde dann würde
das wahrscheinlich sogar reichen könnte
durch vier jahre reisen schon die ein
oder andere erfahrungen zu können
[Applaus]
[Musik]
nächste frage in welchen ländern
außerhalb europas drastisch und bunt wie
bei allen jahren bist du das erste mal
geflogen
außerhalb europa in welchen ländern
außerhalb europas war sie schon als
teenager in osteuropa
doch es ist ja auf jeden fall ist es
außer grube und das weiß auch absolut
jeder entschuldigt was würdest du was
wissen ist ein fucking südasien oder
nicht gerade jetzt mal geflogen
ich sage jetzt mal mit vier songs also
wirklich du hast du schon in ägypten
stunden also ich war bisher in namibia
und also weil er kein anderer in amerika
also in größer und auf samariter das ist
so eine insel in der karibik jahren zum
ersten mal geflogen bin ich mit 15 in
der elften klasse bei einem austausch
nach england wobei ich war kann ich 15
ich war einfach von 17 chf instrumente
nachmachen war schon gut
walter der sich durch ist am anfang viel
liebe die nati kefir fragt was machst du
am liebsten in der freizeit welches
derzeit also in meiner freizeit
nachricht eigene videos so und er weil
du keine verdammten sozialer kontakt ist
und keine hobbys und keine freunde was
bist du denn in meinem leben die biker
wäre ich habe schon natürlich frei
zeitaufwand geburtstag habe ich auch
noch ganz nach nichts gemacht und halte
dann aber echt sehr sehr wie gewöhnlich
normal habe ich also entweder schon
entweder halte entweder haben sie wie
oder mache ich eigene videos zum
beispiel heute nacht werde ich
durchmachen damit morgen ein wie und
dann kommen kann am samstag im a team
gefragt hättest du als kind jemals
gedacht für einen youtuber zu arbeiten
beziehungsweise videos schneiden und ein
kind ja gar kein youtube zu einer kinder
gab es doch kein youtube das ist
wahrscheinlich weil man zuschauen
anderes niveau bei also meine kinder zur
seite mit welver oder 11 gab es auf
jeden fall schon youtube glaubt zum
erstmal habe ich mit neun oder zehn
jahren von toten gehört und dachte also
um ehrlich zu sein hatte ich schon so
eine ahnung aber noch nicht so mit zwölf
sondern er somit 16
gemacht
[Musik]
ja leute das was von diesem video ich
hoffe es hat euch gefallen guckt jetzt
auf jeden fall beim philipp das dann
auch beim leon vorbei und wenn auch
dieses video gefallen hat lassen ihn
gerne daumen rumba oder nach unten von
jutta und schreiben in die kommentare
was er davon gehalten haben wenn ihr
mich weiter auf dieser reise begleiten
wollte dann abonniert doch gerne und
dann sehen uns im nächsten wieder gut
[Musik]